It has been said
through the ages
without sacrifice
there can be no victory
two species at war
one flesh
one metal
Optimus Prime has left us
One Hundred Billion Trillion Planets in the Cosmos
you want to know don't you?
why they keep coming here
I want to stay
and I want to fight them
and now, two worlds colliding
the operation is over
we're not givin' up okay!
only one survives
oh my god
forgive me
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie
so if you're wondering what's going
on there's transformers in the time of King
Arthur all totally explain.
It's called the last night, but the film mostly
takes place in present day I've also got some
news about the Spider-Man homecoming trailer
that I'll explain at the end of this, but
there's a whole bunch happening this week
with a bunch of midseason finale's for the
comic book TV shows to be sure to subscribe
to get everything and make sure you enable
alerts so you don't miss any of the videos,
but that right there looks like some hard-core
Optimus prime on bumblebee violence and I
know people wonder like is that you know Unicron
so they invited a whole bunch of websites
to the film set to learn things about the
film want as you can have Megan running they
change the way that they make transformer
films they have like a story group now and
they're trying to write more from the pre-existing
mythologies like if you watch the classic
cartoons Jen one all through the series up
to now you'll probably see a lot of Easter
eggs but they did say the villain of this
movie is something different that they haven't
done before, like the last couple of villains
have all been relatively comparable to Optimus
prime just different leader versions of transformer
deceptive con transformers.
So it feels like they're getting closer to
you to chron territory or whatever it is the
builders race that Optimus prime went after
in the last movie, so it sounds like what
they did is they had an idea for a movie.
Follow-up to Optimus prime's mission to go
fight the builders but then combined it with
a little more fantasy.
So you see flashbacks to King Arthur and his
knights the idea of the last night just kind
of spreads across the entire film like Optimus
prime is one of the last night King Arthur
in his knights you see they brought back Josh
Duhamel he wasn't in the last film I was like
Mark Wahlberg's bigotry into the franchise.
So there teaming up then this actress Laura
Haddox is basically like the new female protagonist
of the film she's this English character that's
really important to saving the earth but doesn't
really understand how that were so she's part
of mythology they would really reveal how
that's gonna work, but she might just have
like a genetic link to King Arthur that has
something to do with defeating the villain
of the film.
They also confirm that gridlock is coming
backs will have some Dinobots he's gonna wreck
the shit out of a bunch of stuff but Anthony
Hopkins was probably the biggest surprise
for me.
I knew he was going to be in the film, but
it's so funny that they drop this right after
the Westworld finale.
So it sounds like a lot of the mythology.
The fantasy elements of the film will flow
from his character in present day.
But this new transformer is called squeaks
he kinda partners up with this girl here is
there to the new protagonist.
So another really cool transformer.
That's debuting is a submarine transformer
that just looks like a giant octopus is pretty
bad ass and they did confirm that they will
explore the history of the primes like Optimus
prime is just the latest prime in a line of
primes.
So you see them floating here in outer space
that just him in the wake of what happened
after the last film left off do something
really terrible happens he hits a low point
has to decide whether or not he wants to continue
being a leader like you see the bumblebee
fight there might be a fight for the leadership
matrix, which makes me think of the original
Transformers movie that was all about the
leadership matrix defeating you to chron so
it would be really cool thing included them
in a film and they're doing ego the living
planet and guardians of the galaxy.
So giant planet size villains aren't off the
table as long as you do them in really cool
way this might be Megatron, but he typically
doesn't use a sword, so might be one of the
other new transformers usually Megatron changes
more than the other characters like they don't
change Optimus prime that much is given some
more cool toys to play with like last time
you got the sword, but he doesn't have the
classic red coloring here's this is deafly
not Optimus prime limit what you guys think
of the trailer in a generally I think of the
transformer franchise it just like fun popcorn
pulpy action films something you like you
know pretty much what you're getting when
you go into it.
So I think it's interesting the trying to
introduce them fantasy elements to this haven't
really been keeping up a lot with the animated
series since like the first couple generations
like one of the last big series that I watched
on a regular basis was be stores and that
was a long time ago.
So if you guys are like big fans of the transformer
series right now you guys can let me note
you think of this or if you haven't watched
it a long time but fun fact, Michael Bay shot
this movie on almost the exact same type of
camera that James Gunn shot guardians of the
Galaxy to want is a new version of the red
weapon helium 8K sensors of any of you guys
are camera geek both of them got slightly
different variations of the same red weapon
helium camera just tweaked a little bit in
different ways to suit the different types
of scenes they should like Michael Bay James
Gunn shoot very different types of film.
So even though it's the same camera you sent
to set them up in slightly different ways
but is love the idea of Dragon transformers
in the time of King Arthur.
It just makes you think of game of robot thrones
or something like that.
This is just the first trailer.
So we don't learn about the actual story of
the film just to see like this giant planet
size transformer looking like it's coming
to eat the earth.
You know chron style.
You can kind of guess that they have to stop
that.
But whatever the main action of the film is
the deceptive console is a big problem.
So there's always like small boss fights that
you have like the big boss fight which they
kind of teased, with like that and roll into
the text where you like inside the giant robot
then you come out just why I keep thinking
of you know chron they still can have to address
the end of the last film with Optimus prime
going after the creators, so that just might
be the creators pushing back but the producers
have been teasing a new type of ministry villain
so it might not be the creators, otherwise
I think they would've just said that like
oh the people that Optimus prime went to stop
their coming for us now so that kind of confirms
that it's gonna be somebody totally different,
but usually like the second the third trailer
are more story-based trailers they give you
a better idea of why we go to all these different
time periods why it's important it probably
just provides lineage to the new female protagonist
Anthony Hopkins character.
They probably give us are linked to the fantasy
elements the King Arthur.
During the film that Spider-Man homecoming
trailer news.
So it turns out that there was like some fake
stuff going around the of the day the people
tried to discredit so apparently there's no.
Spider-Man homecoming trailer.
But then the agents of shield actors were
teasing that they had a special teaser after
the midseason finale Tuesday night so there
is some special trailer that's gonna air,
but most people feel like it's gonna be something
different for the marvel universe something
from the TVs or the movies but there is some
sort of special trailer after agents of shield.
So whatever it is all totally do a video for
it, but the flash versus savitar with Jay
Garrick midseason finale is tomorrow night
two so there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff happening.
So trying get those videos out as fast as
possible but I'm just so happy that all the
stuff is dropping right now it's gonna be
awesome what you guys wait for that to post
you can click here to rewatch the guardians
to trailer and you can click here for my Westworld
finale video.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!